chemical abortions exist so basically
you're poisoning the baby bang on well
yeah
[Music]
but I I don't believe that abortion is
murder you don't believe abortion is
murder but everything else what do you
think um you see I'm not religious so
it's not really um in my right topic
people my friend here he's very
knowledgeable as well all right so who
is anybody Muslim here I'm I'm half I'm
Muslim yeah you're Muslim yeah you're
Muslim yeah I read the Quran daily so
you believe so you're Muslim it's more
about knowledge I feel like I should be
knowledgeable about what I speak Goa
gotcha gotcha okay fair enough that's I
like that hum mindset all right so we'll
talk about abortion then it's it's
interesting you're the first uh
religious person that we actually got to
to engage with this so yeah so so tell
me uh as a Muslim you say abortion is
not why well I feel like if you get
raped and you get impregnated without
your own will especially if you're in a
difficult position emotionally and
financially you may not feel like you
can have a child and raise a child
adequately to where they'd be raised to
a good condition and a good standard
condition which may lead you into the
abortion pathway so is that okay to kill
the baby because you can't probably
afford it living well before that before
that of a certain I wouldn't say age of
a certain uh maturity certain
development certain development so at
what development is it okay to and
answer this
question at what development is it okay
to kill a baby 24 weeks but I would say
development you should kill a baby I
would say 24 weeks is the legal answer
so 24 weeks should be okay to kill a
baby yes because that's when it's got a
hot so you're so you so you're
acknowledging that the baby is dying the
baby it's it's m the thing is I wouldn't
feel I don't feel like it's a a baby at
that point what is it it's a it's a it's
a UK carote it's a fetus it's a fetus
that's Latin for infant it's an embryo
insect fetus fetus is Latin for infant
do you speak Latin I don't but I know
that word yeah but you know the words
that support your argument yes that's
right okay but I think that I
think it's cuz you can't kill something
which doesn't have a heart and it
doesn't have a you can't kill someone
that do have a
heart but let's go with this you can't
kill somebody that doesn't have a heart
so what about the people who who who are
breathing off of machines right their
heart doesn't work they are breathing
off of machines so how are they is it
okay to kill them
well the thing is I feel like they they
still they still have they still have a
fully developed heart and they've lived
they've lived life they they that they
can make decisions so what if someone
doesn't have a fully developed heart
right they don't and let's say they
can't they're unconscious they can't
make decisions they're unconscious their
heart is based on a machine is it okay
to kill them well if you're unconscious
I feel like their family also their
family also has a decision in that
matter cuz I know in some countries like
in Switzerland it's legal to be
euthanized and it's like if your family
is spending a lot of money which and
they're really uh emotionally stressed
about the situation and Not only would
it make them feel better it would make
them have a lot better life if they were
to make that decision on your behalf
could be allowed so basically your your
argument is tending is turning to
convenience it's inconvenient for the
person who's having the baby it's
inconvenient for the family so therefore
they should be able to get rid of it I
completely agree with you that okay so
let's say two consenting adults yeah
right get pregnant yeah but they're or
they don't have the means to take care
of a child should they be allowed to
kill their baby yeah because you also
got to think about the child's
livelihood as well if the child the
child will if they can't eat properly if
they can't they can't like they're not
in suitable living conditions if they
have to sleep outside if they have to
sleep on the street or something like
that like that's also their decision to
make like so so so here's the next one
so what about a one-year-old let's say
not a one-year-old let's say a 3 month a
poor family gives birth three-month old
baby they have no means to support the
family they live outside under a bridge
they don't have food or water should
they be able to kill the baby to put it
out of its M no they shouldn't because
the baby's been born at that point and
has a heart so all so the only thing
that you're the only thing that you're
basing it on now is location one is the
they're in the womb so it's okay to kill
the baby then but if it's outside the
womb it's not okay to kill it yeah also
the other thing is the baby doesn't
suffer when you kill it as well is
abortion how how how do you know have
you seen an abortion how do you know
that uh baby 24 weeks I if you if you go
to uh um if you go on you you're funny
dude there's this YouTube channel uh
what is her name I'm forgetting her name
bro all all you got to do is put in on
YouTube what happens during abortion
videos will pop up they use a vacuum and
in the vacuum when they stick it into
the woman it sucks the pieces of the of
the baby piece by piece you got to go to
the mic got to go to the m so piece by
piece and and and by the way you you'll
feel the the vacuum will jerk because
the baby is fighting the the pool of the
vacuum yeah but chemical abortions
exist chemical abortions exist chemical
abortions exist can you explain what
that is well I mean it's where you take
a I'm not I don't I'm not sure of the
details but it's not a physical one
where you have to have an operation you
take a tablet or something and it's like
it happens inside without having to do
that kind of so without having to so
basically you're poisoning the baby got
to bang on well yeah but it's okay to
poison babies
well is it okay to Bur the baby into a
world where it's probably going to die
anyway and potentially it's it's it's
it's okay to give the baby a chance to
live or you can give the baby up to
adoption where a happy family would
gladly take care of the baby right or
the child will be stuck in the social
system and kind of suffer worse in its
own way but there's been people that
have gone through that sorry there's
been people that have been born in these
circumstances let's even say born
through rape born in poor families and
they've gone to be amazing people
doctors and nurses you know the
statistic of the people that get saved
and's the statistic when when is a baby
a baby a baby is a baby at conception
the moment of conception there's a new
DNA oh what if we disagree that fetus is
fetus isuk they disagree though fetus is
the Latin word for infant so whenever
you guys say it's not a baby it's just a
a fetus you're just saying it's not a
baby it's just a baby what's the Latin
word for embryo I don't know I don't
know if they have that but it's still a
baby you know I think we should agree to
disagree I I don't know I don't know
when it's an EMB cells it's a group of
cells a group it's not just a group of
cells there's a lot there there's a
there's a new
DNA DNA and then bacteria is a group of
well
bacteria is it okay to kill bacteria
that's the exact same thing okay let's
let's pause it for a second now for
example will you go to jail for killing
bacteria will you go to jail for getting
an abortion in some states exactly in
some states you will so so so I you know
what how about this here's another good
question when when there is a when
there's a car watch this when there when
there's a car accident watch this when
there's a car accident right and there's
a pregnant mother who's in this car
accident her and her baby di do you know
what the what the person is charged with
two man double yeah double manslaughter
why why are they charged with double
manslaughter that's that's how that's
how you said it's out dated that's the
state is in no see because they look
it's it's hypocritical one at one
standard they acknowledge the person
that's within the baby and then in
another standard and then another
standard they
don't oh oh tell them hey hey guys
uh appr you what the ti Tok the it's
YouTube God logic apologetics so put in
God logic pop right up
okay everybody with her Dam hey y'all
are so cool man appreciate y'all man
thank you take care oh my God logic
[Music]